the latest in the oscar slap controversy
chris rock was spotted out for the first
time since the incident as oscar host
wanda sykes goes all in on will
and i just was like is this really
happening and then someone showed me on
the video videos like yeah he smacked
chris
and i just felt so
awful for my friend you know chris and
it was it was sickening i physically
felt ill and i'm still a little
traumatized
me too and for them
to let him stay in that room
and enjoy the rest of the show
and accept his award i was like how
gross is this this is just the wrong
message for them to let him
continue i thought i thought it was was
gross yeah i think i wanted to be able
to run out you know after he won and say
uh unfortunately will couldn't be here
tonight
while wanda was blasting will to ellen
her pal chris was focusing on hitting
the stage tonight chris how are you man
hey can i ask you a couple questions
that's chris just after landing in
boston in these exclusive picks the 57
year old in a grey sweatsuit looked down
and avoided questions the comedian was
spotted again last night outside his
hotel e.t has learned extra security has
been added for his two shows tonight and
it could get pretty interesting we're
told there has not been a reconciliation
with will the two have not spoken in
this town
when is the last time you heard somebody
apologize
this morning on stage tyrese told me
he's 100 percent team will we in this
town we lack accountability there was an
action there was a mistake and this man
apologized and i have to appreciate that
i'm still going to allow myself to
support will smith for the rest of my
life
meanwhile co-host amy schumer spoke out
writing she is still triggered and
traumatized i think violence is never
the answer but
you know we we all do things or say
things that we're not proud of her who
was a presenter told me she left the
dolby theater before the slap jimmy
fallon's take the man chris presented
the win to is also a victim i felt like
as a fan of quest that his moment got
overshadowed by will smith i was crying
when quest won the oscar the incident
happened it was unfortunate and i just
wish it didn't happen but it did but we
celebrated when quest got back
and there was more drama yesterday
amidst the report that it's possible
that the l.a city attorney could file
criminal charges against will deputies
were called to the smith's home
responding to a report of a drone flying
above the estate authorities found
nothing
as for will's future with the academy
today it's taking action oh an emergency
meeting is expected tonight to discuss
hollywood's response to will smith's
attack oh wow sunday night's oscar
assault is still very much an evolving
topic the academy tells e.t today it has
initiated disciplinary proceedings
against will and adds that he was asked
to leave the ceremony and refused any
disciplinary action will take a few
weeks and could include anything from
banning will from future oscar
ceremonies to having his membership
suspended or revoked entirely a brawl
on a stage
in front of three billion people why
wouldn't he be the adult today view
co-host whoopi goldberg who's on the
board of the academy fiercely defended
chris rock the right thing was done
because the man knows how to act in
public a source tells e.t will is
regretful and aware there will be
repercussions he's focused on keeping
his family safe but were chris and will
both triggered by their past
all of these black women that i get to
protect
and
and shine a light on there was a time in
my life where i was concerned with you
know
being a movie star that concern has
moved on will admitted in his biography
released in november that he's put on a
tough hollywood persona to hide the
coward
the coward yeah i was probably nine and
i watched my father
beat up my mother and i was too scared
to do anything i was never going to be
scared again childhood violence also
affected chris's life the struggles
played out in his autobiographical
sitcom everybody hates chris
i was bullied ridiculously i was a
little guy and i was black right so i'm
getting double bullied in january on
dana carvey and david spade's podcast
chris explained how retaliating with
violence left him scarred i went home
i put a
brick
in a book bag and smack this guy in the
face with this brick and stomp to joe
pesci style to the point we thought he
might die as my shrink puts it to me you
have been scared to be angry ever since
will has not approached chris and his
family and i think it requires perhaps
some sort of
phone call i think when everybody stops
looking that may happen there's just too
much heat
just want to reiterate that the two have
not spoken from what we hear
chris is willing to have a man-to-man
face-to-face sit down